[Music]
on this wednesday night inflation nation
living in canada keeps getting more
expensive it's taking a big bite of my
paycheck advice for people in debt and
how to offset rising food costs
new concerns cropping up about
fertilizer and food supplies it's not
like something we can just wrap up
production the growing frustration and
pressure on farmers
the last stand in mariopol a ukrainian
army commander calls on the world to
save civilians who may have only hours
left
[Music]
plus ways you can help bring ukrainians
to canada
and royal relations it was great it was
just so nice to see her what prince
harry said about the queen that's put
some noses out of joint
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we start with something you already know
the price of almost everything is on the
rise and the era of low inflation is
coming to an end canada's inflation rate
hit 6.7 percent in march that's up more
than one percent from february and marks
the fastest year-over-year inflation
jump since january 1991 which was 31
years ago the price of gas is the
biggest factor it's up about 40 percent
compared to this time last year and high
gas prices are accelerating the cost of
everything that needs to be shipped
including food russia's war in ukraine
coupled with supply chain problems are
messing with the world economy abigail
beeman explains what's behind rising
inflation and what it means for you in
our top story tonight
i don't even want to hit the button
because it's a dollar 84
which is absolutely crazy i think that's
the highest i've seen it so far the
sticker price at the pumps just keeps
shocking i didn't see i fill up with a
smile but
i have to fill it up for people like
george abukir it's crazy there's no way
around filling up he's a courier taking
a big bite of
my paycheck gas prices rose 12 percent
in march and year over year a whopping
40 percent overall inflation hit 6.7
percent the biggest month over month
increase since 1991. we're paying more
for
everything
groceries gas durable goods food prices
soared 8.7 percent year over year the
biggest hike since 2009. i am worried i
think my husband are going to have to
sit down and tighten our belts part of
that linked to the war in ukraine
ukraine and russia are big wheat
producers the lack of ukrainian grains
on the world market has an effect on the
food prices around the globe pasta
prices jumped 18 percent cereal 12
percent year over year the best way to
save right now is is on the back end of
the food shopping exchange which is
really
at home
reducing food waste
so if you buy something to eat
make sure you eat it to get a sense of
inflation's record climb take a look at
this five-year chart it also shows just
how much of the rise is due to gas
prices the white line is the consumer
price index without gasoline we're
realizing
that we constricted supply quite a bit
and then you add into this the invasion
of ukraine there is really no
major end in sight for this and so
prices are going to remain very high
the cpi does not include diesel which
energy expert dan mctag says has climbed
even higher than the 40 percent unleaded
hike nor does it factor in the canadian
dollar i think inflationary numbers are
much higher than that not to
sensationalize or create some kind of
scare mongering on that so the best
advice is to not take on more debt in a
higher interest rate environment with
everyone wondering when not if the next
interest hike will come from the bank of
canada
abigail beeman global news ottawa
canadian grain farmers are wondering
what 2022 will bring in places on the
prairies where snow has melted it is
seeding time and the cost of fertilizer
has gone through the roof there's a
global shortage made worse by russia's
war in ukraine canada is the world's
largest producer of potash used in
fertilizer accounting for nearly 32
percent of the world's total and russia
and belarus produced nearly 40 percent
of the global supply along with other
key soil nutrients heather urex west
explains what that means for farmers and
for the food supply
and then in 24 hours it's plus 11. it's
seeding time in southern alberta and
stephen vanderwaal is already concerned
prices are great so they can't complain
about that but inputs are skyrocketing
skyrocketing might not even the word
it's just gone
crazy to the point of um we're not able
to even get some product and and you
can't potentially even afford to put it
in the ground
but there is pressure on these fields to
perform because the war in ukraine is
now putting millions in europe the
middle east and africa at risk of having
too little food
last month at the nato summit in
brussels canada's prime minister
promised this country would be there to
help the issue of food security how we
can ensure that at home
we're planting as much as possible and
that
is something that canada can contribute
to it's difficult to watch that to be
honest it's
coming from a government who knows very
little about agriculture first of all
farmers grow as much as we can every
year it's not like something we can just
wrap up production particularly as the
costs of fertilizer and fuel soar
the challenges go beyond rising input
costs many farms across the prairies are
coming off one of the worst drought
seasons in decades and as seeding begins
here in southern alberta the fields are
very dry 2021 was not a good year and
and the reason why it matters so much
this year is because we're starting
the new year 2022 with really low
inventories typically you would actually
have something to sell or something to
work with but that's not the case in
2022 it also means seeds for this year's
crop are in short supply unfortunately
in in the federal budget a couple of
weeks ago there was really no provisions
to help farmers with any inputs
whatsoever farmers will just have to cut
back on what they do which means they'll
cut back on yield and in a global grain
shortage that is the opposite of what
the world needs from canada heather urex
west global news near fort mcleod
alberta
a little later some advice from a
personal finance counselor about how
best to deal with rising costs and
interest rates first though to ukraine a
fighter holed up in mary opal says
hundreds of civilians may have only
hours left to live and that russian
troops outnumber his fighters ten to one
it appears to be a last stand in the
besieged city ukraine's president says
weapons from the west are key to
survival
in order to unblock marijuana there are
two ways
first
serious
and
heavy weapons that we are counting on we
don't have enough
of these weapons in order to work in
this direction second way is diplomatic
so far russia does not agree to this
canada has committed to sending heavy
artillery to ukraine but how much and
when is unclear the prime minister
wouldn't give any further details today
and late today the pentagon in the u.s
said ukraine has not received entire
fighter jets from any country only parts
for fighter jets the spokesperson said
today he was mistaken jackson proskow on
what ukraine needs right now
a small column of buses attempted to
leave mariupol as the mayor urged
residents to flee the russian onslaught
but the corridor did not work as planned
according to ukraine's deputy prime
minister
a ceasefire did not hold mariupol is
still under siege the conditions there
the situation there as a result
of this russian aggression are truly
horrific throughout the day smoke could
be seen billowing from that sprawling
steel compound in the city
the final refuge for hundreds of
ukrainian troops and civilians
reportedly including canadians
surrounded by russian forces
we are probably facing our last days if
not hours said this ukrainian commander
as he appealed for rescue by a third
party country
the kremlin shows no sign of backing
down as it carries out its new offensive
in a fresh sign of defiance vladimir
putin oversaw a test of a new russian
intercontinental ballistic missile which
he boasted could penetrate modern
missile defenses
food for thought he said for those who
try to threaten our country
the west remains equally undeterred
the president of the european council
visited key then promised another 1.5
billion euros in military aid after
seeing the devastation these are
atrocities these are war crimes it must
be punished it will be punished they
must pay for what they have done
the u.s said it would provide another
800 million dollars worth of military
equipment in the form of long-range
artillery
the pentagon will also soon begin
training ukrainian troops at a location
in europe it's meeting exactly the needs
they have at this point in the war
but help likely won't arrive soon enough
to halt the russian advances in the east
back on the streets of mariupol
residents stuck behind searched for food
and charged their phones
keeping critical connections to the
outside world working
knowing their port city may soon be
firmly in russian control
jackson prosko global news washington
the number of people fleeing ukraine is
staggering the u.n refugee agency
estimates more than 5 million people
have left the country since russian
forces invaded less than two months ago
that's an increase of more than one
million refugees in just the last three
weeks the agency says it believes
another 13 million are displaced from
their homes inside the country
canada has said it will accept an
unlimited number of ukrainians and
there's an effort now to streamline the
process it's a collaboration between
three groups including the federal
government ross lord reports
with more than 54 000 ukrainian refugees
approved to come to canada there's a
sharper focus on details like how they
get here the federal government is
teaming up with air canada to provide
more flight options having the benefit
of this new program announced today
will no doubt change the travel plans
for many individuals in terms of whether
they would wait for a government charter
or take a commercial option we're going
to make a narrow plan donation of 100
million points
this donation will give the flexibility
to of travel on the star alliance global
network
an american agency the shapiro
foundation promises to match donations
from canadians who donate their frequent
flyer points or give money to the cause
for some ukrainians who've already
arrived in canada though the convoluted
immigration system is presenting some
wrinkles in nova scotia these ukrainian
refugees are facing twelve hundred
dollars of medical screening costs
something advocates say can
re-traumatize people in their time of
greatest need the individuals that are
arriving
are going to be and have begun to arrive
are lone parent families single women
um grandparents
and so
um with limited income immigration
minister sean fraser suggests obstacles
to health care and education are a work
in progress
when we've been having conversations
with our provincial and territorial
partners a large focus is
what can we do to have those other
levels of government extend health and
education services provinces like
alberta say they're ready for an
accelerated influx of ukrainians
additional support from alberta we
estimate of two million dollars of
support to provide
rapid settlement support
based on canada's experience welcoming
other refugees over the years advocates
say it's unlikely to be a seamless
transition but it's a safe bet canada
will be a lot more secure than the lives
they are leaving behind
ross lord global news
a saskatchewan first nation has
identified 14 possible burial sites at a
former residential school after months
of work in three ground searches the
george gordon first nation about an
hour's drive north of regina says 14
potential graves were found close to the
site of the original school it was one
of the longest running residential
schools in the country it closed in
1996. the national center for truth and
reconciliation has a record of 49
student deaths there
[Music]
and the federal government is providing
funding for the investigation of
potential unmarked graves at the site of
a former residential school in nova
scotia 326 thousand dollars has been
earmarked for search operations on the
grounds of the former schubernachery
indian residential school it was the
largest in atlantic canada the money
could also help pay for healing programs
and commemorative events or structures
coming up who's in the conservative
leadership race and who's likely to
appeal to voters outside the party
[Music]
the deadline for candidates to enter the
federal conservative leadership race has
come and gone and at least eight people
have submitted the required paperwork
and the fifty thousand dollar
registration fee there's still a long
way to go before the leadership vote in
september but a new ipsos poll done
exclusively for global news shows
there's already a clear front-runner
among the party faithful our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports
in downtown toronto tuesday and over the
last month elsewhere across canada
pierre poliev has been drawing
unprecedented crowds visible evidence of
new polling data from ipsos provided
exclusively to global news that inside
his party at least pauliev is the most
popular leadership candidate among those
polled by ipsos who said they'll vote
conservative in the next election 32
percent said they want pauliev to be
leader just 14 percent picked former
quebec premier jean charret but when
ipsos asked those who identified as
liberal voters who they thought would be
best to lead the conservatives 40
percent had a positive view of charade
just 21 percent had a positive view of
polyeth the key takeaway for us here is
that uh conservative party members have
a clear choice between two different
strategies go with the populist favorite
of the party's base like pauliev or pick
a leader like cheray who may have more
potential to appeal to voters outside
the party
one thing for conservatives to consider
that moderate image that aaron o'toole
presented in last summer's election was
in fact a big problem at one point for
the trudeau liberals at the start of the
campaign there was a lot of potential
that came from that that moderate appeal
dan arnold was the pollster inside the
liberal election war room in 2021 and he
says there was a point in the last
campaign when he was telling the trudeau
team they were on the path to lose to a
moderate conservative certainly the
trajectory the way things were going was
uh was headed to a very unpleasant place
from uh from our perspective there and
that is the campaign's divide right now
capture the base or broaden the base now
as for leslie lewis patrick brown and
the others in the race the ipsos poll
says the vast majority of canadians
simply do not know enough about them yet
to have an opinion donna
all right david in ottawa thanks
priceless advice ahead some tips on
navigating the soaring cost of living
[Music]
hearing that canada's inflation rate in
march was 6.7 percent is probably not a
huge shock for a lot of people because
of course people are living it the price
of almost everything is up and interest
rates are rising too managing your money
is getting trickier with me is pamela
george she's a personal finance
counselor pamela thanks for for speaking
with us you know everyone's personal
circumstances are different of course
but let's start with the broad strokes
for people carrying lots of credit and
mortgage debt who got used to low
interest rates and now see that is
rising plus inflation what is the first
thing they should do
well the first thing song's a bit cliche
but um visit your budget and if you
don't have a budget get one going
and one when you're doing that i would
say the first thing to really tackle in
terms of reducing your cost to help you
meet the cost of living these days
i find a good tip is to look at your
subscriptions you know it was 599 10.99
global uh disney plus all those uh you
know audible all of that it adds up and
that is one way you can start tackling
all the the high cost of living that's
happening right now yeah that is a good
tip among the fastest rising costs of
course are gas and food even dollarama
says it's going to start selling things
that cost five dollars so apart from
making do with less what other
strategies can people adopt
well i you know
if you have a car as an example like you
just said gas is going up gas is so high
now
what about taking public transit leave
your car at home ditch it for a while be
not saying it's going to be forever but
over the next few months leave your car
at home and use public transit that's
what i do and it's working out fine for
me
what if borrowing money is the only
option though what is the most
affordable way to do that right now
i want to go back a little bit and say
before you look at borrowing money if
you have an emergency fund if you have
some money put aside that you can easily
access without it causing you a penalty
that's the first place you want to go so
to withdraw some money from that to
supplement your lifestyle right now when
that is finished then you can look at
going into borrowing credit and the
first place you really want to do that
is on a secured line of credit that's
usually the cheapest
after that is a regular line of credit
and then well your credit cards what you
want to stay away from is the payday
loans and the high interest loans that i
know it's available out there as well
stay away from the payday loans oh gosh
as much as you can yes
i know you do credit counseling you have
clients what are you hearing from them
these days
people are in panic right now they are
worried that they cannot support their
lifestyle right now they're concerned
that the income is not enough
for their current living expenses they
are panicking
it's anxiety is very high in my job
right now when i talk to my clients and
what do you what do you tell them to try
to calm them
well a little bit of old school things
like meal planning i know it's cliche
again but it really makes a big
difference look for the sales in the
supermarket buy in bulk if you can
um one thing that my husband and i do we
usually shop every week but once every
quarter we don't and that
we save about two hundred dollars by not
shopping for that one week we just shop
what we have in the house use what we
have and that really adds up to about
eight hundred dollars a year
makes a difference sure does those are
useful tips pamela george a financial
counselor in ottawa thank you
thank you so much for having me love her
advice kinship with the queen next what
prince harry said about his grandmother
that's raising questions
the royal cavalry was rehearsing in
london's hyde park in advance of the
royal windsor horse show next month
always a highlight of queen elizabeth's
calendar she turns 96 tomorrow a
milestone she'll mark out of the
spotlight at a farmhouse on her country
estate of sandringham a favorite spot of
her late husband prince philip she has
appeared more frail after he died and
has cut back on some royal duties
because of mobility issues now news of a
surprise visit from her grandson prince
harry and his wife megan last week is
making headlines in an interview with
nbc harry made some cryptic comments
about making sure the queen is protected
it was just so nice to see her you know
she's on she's ungrateful and always
she's always got a great sense of humor
with me and i'm just making sure that
she's you know protected and got the
right people
harry also said he feels at home living
in california now he avoided answering a
question about whether he misses his
brother william and father charles and
claimed he is one of the queen's closest
confidants
so it's our sense of humor yeah and her
ability to see the the humor in so many
so many different things we have a
really special relationship we talk
about things that you can't talk about
with anybody else
his grandmother will mark 70 years on
the throne with platinum jubilee
celebrations in early june harry says
he's not sure if he and his family will
be there because of what he calls
security issues
and this new photo of the queen was just
released taken on the grounds of windsor
castle she's with two of her beloved
fell ponies buyback katie and
buyback nightingale beautiful shot that
is global national for this wednesday
i'm donna friesen tonight's your canada
is these sun dogs near winnipeg we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to us and thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you